[Music]
[Applause] What
's up? Are you feeling unwell? I was
sleeping a little.
[Music] I can't take on the
two enemy birds like this. Torque.
When the fruits are brought in, you push the front all at once.
You're a good dice player.
Well.  That's fine, but how are you able to
stop the enemy in your tracks? How can you be so
nimble? [
Music]
Telling yourself that your voice is only for survival [
Music] From the
bottom of your heart [
Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
Everyone could feel it, right?
[Applause] [
Music] I
don't feel anything [
Music]
[Applause] [Music
] [
Applause] [Music] [Music
Music]
[Music] Ah,
trophy
sheep food.  I'd like some milk, please.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music]
[Music]
After leaving Markland, our ship
sailed further south, and the
wind told us that there was a richer land.
I've found a
new continent, a
new land where fruits are ripe and the meadows are rippling. I've
given it a name.
[Music]
Her name is
Finland.
[Music]
Well, I've never looked back on this place before, but I think this
Lef Eriksson is an old
man.  So there were people. It was
bigger than warm Iceland. It was
much warmer than here. The
grass was all over the place. We
also met some natives. We didn't speak the
language, but we quickly became friends.
These
feathers and pipes.  It was a gift from them,
but this one
was something that only a true warrior could acquire.
[Music] What, if you're a
child, I'm sorry you're still awake. I
wanted to tell you Leif-san's story. Is he a
true warrior or an old man?  That's amazing. You're a
good
boy. Tolhin. When you grow up, you're
going to board my ship. I'm going to put you on board now. It's weird even now, Mr. Leif. Grandpa
told me that in the west there is
Jormungandr, and he eats all the ships that come close.
So, there's nothing beyond that.
That's why you can understand how great I am.
Look, look, this is proof of most true warriors. Mr.
Leif, you're not a warrior, right?
Sailors are amazing at fighting the sea, after
all.
Everyone is saying that even children with beards are only adventuring and are
useless in battle. Tolkhin
believes that they should be carried away by those around them. Then this is what an adventurous old man who doesn't go to war says. You
can trust me,
after all.  It's true that my father died in the battle,
but don't make fun of
these guys, just say hello and
do it. It's the end of the day.
Send them all off.
[Music]
That's right. The
investors in Greenland are going to be very strict about this year's fundraising.
Many of the livestock will probably die, but
the problem is that the cold is getting harsher as they get older. Thank you for your
hard work.
These two are the only ones that are weak.
If it's cold, my uncle will warm them up.
Lewd father and
mother. Don't go to sleep again.  It's okay, I'm going to catch a cold. I'll
help you tie the sheep. It looks like it's going to be tough
here too. Well,
someday there may come a winter that no one can survive. My younger
brother is currently
making plans to move to my country, which is
probably far away.
[Music] I've been
back and forth,
Finland is just around the corner. Captain
Dolphin is a
creepy monster. It
hurts.
Go to your own bed, it's small.
[Music] You're sneaky. I
warmed this bed. We're
still talking.
Don't worry.  You don't have to worry. Worrying
is a grown-up's job. That's why it's cute. My
sister will hold me.
[Music]
Why don't we buy slaves? My
mother is weak and I don't have to help her. It's a prediction.
Every year.  Don't listen to me, I'm a
weirdo.
[Music] So I
thought I was going to die. Are you hurt? What's wrong with
this person?
[Music] [
Applause]
Hey, old man, how much of what happened
yesterday is true? I don't
care how much of it, it's all true. How can you believe something like that?  Don't tell me,
if you want to go on a boat, ask your
father to take you on board.I heard that there is also a warship over there that has
been used by the village for generations, but your father would be
happy to win.Your father is
stingy, so no matter how many times you ask him, it won't work.What is stingy
?  No,
these dolphins are scary in the ocean.When I was
young, I was once trapped in an ice floe.I had just
moved to Greenland, so I was
unconscious, and
food ran out quickly.I
ate ice to relieve my feelings of loneliness.
Our ship was crushed by the ice, and we
walked helplessly on the sea.When we woke up, I was the only one
left.All
six of us were dead.Why?Why did
we go to such lengths to live on such a northern island?  It's
coming out
[Music] I'm
boiling water for you. What's going on? Buried
in the snow.
[Music] Wow,
what's this? Please
turn up the fire.
Hey, Dad, he's not dead. His limbs are rotting. He's disgusting.  He's
not from the village,
is he? He's a slave who ran away in such a blizzard.  It's a
nice land,
warmer than here, and the sea doesn't freeze. It's a nice land
protected by many coves.
But one day, a
strong man named Adult appeared.
Arald's army
overpowered Muramura with the force of fire, and he established the first
united Norway.  He claimed to be the ruler
and threatened the people.
[Music]
Obey the king or leave your Norwegian blood.
Many people hated Harald's birth and
moved to a unified place beyond his control.
That's
Iceland.  No, it
's a lie. I'm pushing you. You're a liar after all.
Father, my ancestors would have run away. Dad
's Barca
Adventure
[Music]
Father: I
heard that Leif's uncle is
home Dolphin.
Who is that slave? He
ran away.
I'm back alive,
can you say my name? I'm stronger.
Where did you come from? Am I being
taken back? I
'm a half-half in Lord Halfdan's mansion, after all.
From the other side of the mountain. I do
n't like that place. I don't like it. There's no way I'm
going anywhere. Come on,
half!  The group has come to the port again to
make some trouble. They
can't deal with you unless you're the one. They
forcefully come ashore, saying that they don't care about slaves, and Mr.
Rape, the bastard, steps in between them.  It's about to start, so
come anyway. A
chain is the only necklace that suits a human. It's not gold
or silver, it's an
iron chain.
Only a chain around your neck
can make you a little better. Don't you
think so?
Last night I  Do you have any idea that one of the slaves broke the chain and ran away?
I guess they're
trying to rehash what happened the other day. I've had a lot of trouble with them, and I recently
had the committee mediate with them.
I remember that fight. I
got my left arm cut
off.
[Music] [
Music] You can
only become a human being when you're tied together.
Don't forget, you're the one who
ran away.  It's a young Slavic man. Do you
recognize him?
Where is he?
[Music]
This is the first time I've felt so at ease. Take
care of yourself, you're going to die. Your
mother and
sister were all
here too. I was
worried. They were
sold into pieces, so
here they are.  Where am I? In the
far west,
beyond the sea, there
is a land called Vinland. It's
warm and
rich.
[Music] Neither
slave traders nor the flames of war can reach it. It's
Karaichi. What do you think?
Someday, you'll be there with us.  Why don't you live on the ground?
[Music] Is
this
Finland? I found it.
Forgive my rudeness. I'm the
slave's rightful owner. Let's
get it back. Come on,
Trofin. You see. I did
n't hide your slave.  But I
saved her when she was about to die, so
how much did I buy it for?
Father, it's rude to ask me that. There are
three young, muscular NEET females. I'll buy them. How about half-breeds? I'll
show them off in front of the other slaves I'm taking home.  If you're going to torture them, you'll need
four. I
understand what you said, and in that case, all of them are females under the age of three. [
Music]
What's a sheep to do without failing? [Music] Well, it's a deal.
[Music]
Lies
The deal
is done.
Thors So I broke that guy's chains.
Is
that what you're thinking? So
where are we going to take him? I'll let you choose the sheep.
[Music] [
Applause]
[Laughter]
Sister, it's sad. It's
sad. There were sheep too.  But he
died in a blink of an eye.
[Music]
We also
ran away. Leif's uncle said that
our ancestors fled from the east and
ran away and came here.
So we
ran away from here too.
Where do those who want to go go?
[Music]
[Music] Hey [
Music]
Hold up a strong and certain stone, and sometimes it's
okay to be kind [
Music] I
hug my knees to the blurring scenery [Music]
When my heart runs through my heart, say me
[Music] On the
floor  A
wish that shines on the gray sea The
voices we connect
touch our cheeks to a world without answers
[Music]